خمسه عشره ساعه من حبس الانفاس شهيده
العاصمه الصوماليه بعد اقتحام فندق قرب
قصر الرئاسي بعد انقاذ المسؤولين
الحكوميين بداخله في الساعات الاولى من
العمليه اجتاحت سلطات ساعات اكثر حتى
احتاجت الى ساعه اكثر لانهاء سيطره مقاتلي
حزب الشباب على الفندق وقتلهم كما تقول
الرئيس السومريه يقول لنا بلاده في حرب
عالميه على الارهاب ويطالب المجتمع
الدوليه بدعم حكومه
اذا فقد اعلنت الشرطه الصوماليه انتهاء
عمليه فندق فيلاروس ومقتل 15 شخصا بينهم
سته من المهاجمين والرجل امن صومالي بينما
اصيب خمسه من رجال الامن في الهجوم الذي
شنته حركه الشباب على الفندق بالقرب من
القصر الرئاسي في العاصمه السومريه مقديشو
وطلب الرئيس حسن الشيخ محمود المجتمع
الدولي بالوقوف الى جانب حكومه بلاده من
اجل هزيمه ما وصفهه الارهاب
ينضم لنا من مقديش شو هذا دكتور حسن الشيخ
علي نور المحلل والخبير الامني صور حسن
المستمعين الكرام او المشاهدين الكرام
السابق الذي ارسله اليكم عمر من الصومال
والتقرير الصحيح ولكن اذا اضفت بعض الشيء
هل هذا الهجوم الاخير هو جزء من حلقات
كانت متواليه منذ اكثر من 20 سنه شهيدتها
عاصمه
تفجيرات
واحتسام
بالجدران الفنادق
والابنيه
او المدني التي
كانت تقوم حركه الشباب
انها تنادل من اجل تحقيق لكتاب الله
سبحانه وتعالى وانها تقاتل بمن وصفات
الدين الخارجيين عن الدين هذا زحمهم ولكن
الحقيقه الخلافه ذلك اعتبر انهم دائما
يقتلون الناس المدنيين ويدمرون ممت تشعب
صومالي هذا من الناحيه اما الذي حدث امس
بطبيعه الحال يعني كان هناك تفجيران وقد
سمعت باذنيه ان كانت هناك تفجيرين كبيرين
بفندق قريب بالمقر الرئاسي لجمهوريه
الصومال الفيدراليه
واستمرت العمليات كما قال التقرير التي
قدمه والاخ عمر من مقديشو
رابطعه وقتل من قتل والجريحه من جرح ولكن
[موسيقى]
الصوماليه عاجزه عن وقف هذه العمليه
الحكومه ليست عاجزه وكما سمعتم او قالها
الاعلام العالمي السيد الرئيس حسن شيخ
محمود كان في الخدود الاماميه قبل ثلاثه
ايام على بعد 350 كيلو متر من العاصمه
بمعنى انه ابعد حركه الشباب من العاصمه
اكثر من 300 كيلو متر تقريبا 20 الاخيره
وما زال الجيش الصومالي والقوات الدائمه
يتقدم الى الامام ويسيطر مساحات شاسعه همم
من الصومال التي كانت حركه الشباب اكثر من
عقدين الاخرين ولكن هناك بما يسمى عمليه
التسلل والتسلل اللي هو عباره عن شخص همم
الرئيس
اكبر لمحاربه مواصفه والارهاب كيف تقيم
هذا الدعم الغربي للحكومه الصوماليه
قبل ان قبل ان ان نقيب الدعم الذي يطلبه
الرئيس الصومال لدعم اوضح الصوره لدى
المستمع العربي او شاهد العربي العمليه
يتم عبر التسلل عباره عن اشخاص يعبئون
اجسادهم بالمتفجرات ثم يمشون كبقيه الناس
في الطرقات العامه ثم فجاه يلجؤون الى
فندق او سكن حكومي ثم يفجر نفسه ثم تاتي
بعد ذلك انطلاقات الناريه باناس ايضا
كانوا ايضا تسللوا من هنا وهناك ثم
يتحسنون البنايات والبيوت العاليه ثم
تستمر العمليه بساعات ليس هذا يعني يعود
الى قوه حركه الشباب انما يعود ب همم
النهج الاستراتي او الاسلوب الذي تستخدمه
الحركه همم
من من من من من من مع الشعب وهذا اذن يعني
صعب لكل هم حتى يستفيد
الغى دعوه الرئيس الصومالي لدعمه ضد
الارهاب
ليس ليس فقط الغربي انما دعا المجتمع
الدولي بما فيهما الدول العربيه
والاسلاميه والافريقيه ان تساند الحكومه
الصوماليه لتتقدم الجيش الصعب اللي تقدم
الجيش الصومالي الى الامام والقوات
المواليه او المسانده التي تاتي الشماليه
يعني اقول بكل صراحه بكل صراحه بيقول بكل
صراحه انه هذه الاجراءات وهذه المنطقه
يعني
اقتحابات لا تعني سوى على ان الحركه تريد
ان تبقى في في في المجال الاعلامي الدولي
شكرا دكتور حسن الشيخ علي نور المحلل
الخبير الامريكي المتحدث الثاني